[Music]
foreign
s guess who's back I'm Kristen Bauer
also known as Pam and I'm Deborah Ann
woller as I'm known on True Blood
Jessica Hamby together we're back
hosting season two of truest blood the
official True Blood look back podcast
this time we're heading back to bond
time to recap season two of the show and
discuss how it was made with the people
who made it you'll hear from some of the
season's key players like rutina Wesley
The Shining Star behind Tara Thornton
Fellowship of the sun leaders Anna camp
and Michael McMillan The Season's big
bad Michelle Forbes and Bill Compton
himself Stephen Moyer and you'll hear
from the great minds behind the camera
as well as cinematographer director
Romeo terrone and writer executive
producer rail Tucker will also be
joining us we request your fellowship
each week as we sink our fangs into the
series episode by episode watch the HBO
original True Blood on HBO Max subscribe
share with your fellow trubies and
anyone who isn't one yet and listen on H
Biomax or wherever you get your podcast
[Music]